gonna lie I definitely think that the
world
as we know it because they're talking
about only the West it's just gonna go
back to where it could where it should
be for example in the UK before
colonialism was even there the
imperialism and all of this they were
just peasants even just before the Egypt
even during the Industrial Revolution
peasants that's why you live in white
you live in and it looks like a ghetto
do you see what I mean and because this
is literally what London has been like
other than Central London and a bit of
West everything is just trash step
outside of London it's disgusting the
the society right now the society that
we know the superior ideology is about
to get the reality hitting in his face
the slap is going to come back and
people are going to realize okay it's a
really really is a dog eat dog world
this side of the world here is messed up
they've gone too far with whatever
experimentations they wanted to do we
need to go so I'm just gonna say right
now what a great time to be black and
African true I agree with that too you
know it's just so much better now like
in the past you know I mean like
especially is
like you know what you were saying about
um the mattress or something the elites
wants us to be Dumber it's like you know
when the slavery period
um when we couldn't speak back we were
just going through like a lot of things
then they never wanted to speak back so
people will actually try to advocate for
black people ended up being murdered and
that I mean they just love people to be
Dumber so even now that the internet is
like this it's like we have more like
advantages to speak up and people like
being around and things actually happen
that's why I love this generation more
like social media like everyone can see
anything if someone tells you to shut up
you can say something back but in the
past you can't say anything you're just
gonna shut up do you know what I mean
yeah yeah and that's why slaves can even
read back in the day you know like you
can't read because once you start to
learn how to read you know that that's
what red pill is really it's teaching
slaves to read it's just like men are
like wait a minute yeah I have a right
to have value like oh wait man this
[__] can talk [__] to me like this not
anymore no no no no no I'm running away
do you know I just had this like red
pill moment the other day I watched this
Pastor on YouTube and this is what this
message is so lost in the church because
they don't even talk about like what a
true traditional relationship is and it
was like the woman went up to her
husband or the pastor and said like why
me and my husband keep arguing and the
pastor says well why are you arguing
with your husband he's your boss like he
was like he's your boss right you
wouldn't if if my employees arguing with
me I just fire the employee but like and
it goes and what I realized is I'm like
oh my gosh arguing with a man implies
that you guys are equal yeah and that's
what all the problems are from is like
we think that we are equal when men are
literally better at everything even
cooking and raising kids they're
literally better and it's like Until you
realize that men are literally are like
what do you call it superiors when
they're above you and when you're in a
relationship you are supposed to look at
him as your Superior you are not equals
and and the world is trying to tell us
that we're equal and I know you might
you might Flinch right I used to too but
it's like no think about it think about
it what what has what is a 50 I'm not
there yet
is what
50 okay we want we want traditional men
right typically women want men that open
doors they want men that will protect us
they want men that take up the majority
of the bills typically especially when
we have a family and have kids right so
you're saying take up all the
responsibility but you have no authority
over me I want you to be responsible for
me I want you responsible to protect me
you're responsible to provide for me
even if you work in the long run you're
going to work less than your husband so
he's going to do more work but you have
no Authority you can't tell me what to
do we have to comp even the idea of like
well you have to I heard Michaela
Peterson say this once once she said I
was with a guy that I couldn't negotiate
with and I'm like you're not supposed to
negotiate with your husband you ask it's
the same way like the relationship with
your husband if you look back at truly
traditional relationships it's supposed
to be like a boss and an employee like
not exactly the same but the same type
of dynamic where you might go ask your
boss for your raise but you're not going
to demand it and have a [__] fit if he
doesn't give it to you yeah to be honest
I also would like because I'm a
traditional person myself I didn't grow
up in the UK I grew up in Nigeria and I
was thought that a management to take
care of you that I managed meant to do
this for you do that you're not
traditional you know I mean no I am a
very traditional person let me say it
let me just go okay
I know myself like I want that but it's
like when I moved to the UK I looked
after myself for too much like I was
just it was just me and I had to do a
lot of things by myself like I had to
pay my own rent I didn't have anybody
like I wasn't dating nobody so now that
I'm actually trying to see somebody
again I'm thinking to myself it's hard
for me to let that man do it it's just
so hard I try but when he does some
saying things I'm like I could do that
for myself I could do that for myself
but generally speaking I would like a
man to take care of me but this is okay
this is where we get into the inequal
exchange of value and the things you
don't appear like a traditional woman
you have red hair it's like you have no
no I'm seriously like two traditional
women they don't really wear a lot of
makeup they don't don't get triggered
wait don't get no don't get triggered
come on all right I'm not either I'm not
either it's okay it doesn't mean you're
a bad person but traditional women are
virgins until they're married I'm just
gonna assume you're not a virgin right
traditional version traditional
men like wouldn't wear a top like that
traditional moment
that doesn't mean you're a bad person
I'm not like I'm not saying you're like
a bad and I'm I'm saying I'm not
traditional either yeah but it's like so
the Met like the women are saying I'd
like a traditional man but we're not
coming to the table with a traditional
mindset like we we don't even we we
think that we should be able to
compromise in a relationship that's not
traditional traditional is what he says
goes the traditional okay I'm thinking
when you're saying traditional I'm not
thinking in the same aspect that you're
thinking I'm not traditional but like
it's the West like we've we've done some
let's say the world is more wild right
now you can't expect to see like do you
know I mean you're going traditional
like virgin let's say that's out of the
box already right are you saying don't
dress like that don't put on makeup let
me just don't put on makeup don't have
the same house my set of tradition is
like for me saying oh I'm gonna listen
to my husband I'm gonna cook in the
house I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do
that that's what I see a traditional
because that's what I could do right now
because of what the world is that's just
I know I love it
so I see as traditional not like the
whole version quiet but that's why it's
like it's traditional when it's when
it's easy traditional like when it
benefits me right so and this is wait
wait and it's not it's not to like take
any Digs at you 95 of women are not
virgins on their wedding day but it's
like either we're equals or they're
better than us yeah it's either either
we are these same or we're not and if we
if we're really saying that we are equal
here then then okay pay for half the
dates I do that actually if anyone what
you're saying that I've actually been
with on a day I always offer do you want
me to pay like I said I look after
myself
offering versus actually buying is
different no if you're watching this
right now we've been on a day before
they could come out if you actually I
always go on a date I say can I I said I
want to put in the money I like to pay
because like I would remind you I said I
looked up to myself for so long that I
always think when was your last
relationship I'm literally eating with
somebody right now okay okay and he
makes you so angry
I have a question do you do you split
everything down the middle everything we
don't split everything down
yes or no does he pay more yes or no no
he does okay so he pays equally yeah
because we don't pay my rent I decided
to see yes or no like for wait wait wait
wait wait so so so right now so you do
do the 50 50 then yeah which is fine
there's nothing there's nothing I'm not
I'm not hating on 50 50. I think if you
want to do that fine
we don't do 50 50.
to him sometimes because he spends on
that sits again sometimes you know what
I say let's go out I'll pay for dinner
tonight I'll pay for everything like we
don't live together so I pay my rent and
everything he goes to you and he's like
do you know what I mean I'm not saying
to him even when we spend time to go
because we've been together for like a
while so when we do spend time together
we're not literally doing do not mean
it's not like oh let's go no we're not
doing stuff like that so there's not a
lot of money being spent but like on
past this special place you can get
stuff for me my whole point is that
typically the man pays more no typical
okay I don't I don't I don't yeah I
don't want that oh you find me that okay
I'll tell you then you're you're like
jeopardizing you know it's like I just
can't do it no no it's traditional women
get traditional outcomes if you're not
getting a traditional outcome it's
probably because you're not traditional
and that's the thing is like we've
allowed women to go around saying I'm a
traditional woman I'm a traditional
woman and then I say okay do you listen
to your boyfriend husband whatever no
matter what he says if you disagree it
goes and they'll say no if I asked him
do you argue with him yes uh okay what
about what about cooking what percent of
the meals do you cook oh he has to do
chores too okay uh what about are you a
virgin did you bring virginity to the
table no no but that's a real
traditional we've like brainwashed women
to think that like we are traditional
when we are not your explanation
notation was different from my
experience we all have our own things no
but there's no there's no def there's
the definition that has been there for
all of time but you know what in history
it's long to be talking about being a
traditional woman I'm not a traditional
woman I am an evolved woman not even a
modern woman I'm an evolved woman and
I'll tell you why because I've retained
certain aspects of the traditional that
still are no needed that are still
relevant to today's age
rather than selling a car and I say are
you single yes of course I am now
Jesus Christ okay imagine you're selling
a car right and I have a hot do you know
what Honda Civic is yeah yeah it's like
a typical clock and I say this is a
Ferrari you can go around all the people
that buy Ferraris and say this is a
Ferrari this is Ferrari values but that
doesn't make it a Ferrari because
Ferraris get Ferrari buyers and if
you're single over the age of 25 odds
are you're not traditional because
traditional women get married young that
is their number one priority in life
doesn't mean you're a bad person it
doesn't mean like take anything away
from your value well except to men a
little bit but but it doesn't it doesn't
mean you're a bad person it just means
you're not traditional okay then let's
use that analogy and not put it into a
Tesla okay this car has got a lot of
power wait wait wait no let me tell you
it is not a Ferrari but it can go as
fast as a Ferrari and guess what it's
electric so it's even better for the
environment nowadays what would you
rather you can go for the Ferrari it's
up to you this tastes but for me I
prefer the test I'll give you an example
but you got no Tesla you're single yes I
am single a lot of choice no I'm for
sure I was I was in a relationship for
five years I've been single four years
I'm not ready to go into a relationship
yet because I'm starting to I'm still
trying to kind of settle my foundations
now after five years that's a long time
to be right to be in a relationship to
then go back into the world then we look
at the car specs and say what are the
outcomes for these cars well one dies
after 10 000 miles where one has a long
life and you pick the one with the long
life just because you put new paint and
a new hood on it doesn't make it a new
car yeah but this is gone this is the
thing like modern women have worse
outcomes and we can look at this a
hundred years ago 85 percent of women
were virgins on their wedding day 95 of
people were married 95 yeah today so
yeah I get traditional women ever again
there's no more left yes yes
I would say very very few because the
issue is like traditional women wouldn't
really social media makes it so tempting
for traditional women to not be
traditional that even if you get a
traditional woman she can still go on
social media and get
it all goes down because like you know
everybody thinks and in the west is so
bad right right but you know that inside
I'm talking West you're good you're good
I'll give you a Global Perspective in
Japan right 27 of all women from ages 18
to 39 years old zero percent sexual
experience all virgins 27 of the
population why because they don't have a
mainstream horde media it's like get out
there and suck some dick sister being an
empowered corporate [__] they don't
have that if you watch the commercials
in Japan if you watch commercials in
Korea if you watch Commissions in Japan
in China compared to what you see in the
states it's night and day in Japan they
have women wearing aprons dancing in the
sun celebrating that they're Housewives
and they have like the best laundry
detergent in America it's completely
different from that of course the media
all this stuff the the you know it's not
I'll take the side of saying that it's
not West women's fault in regards to all
the propaganda in the United States in
England Canada Australia all the
English-speaking Western countries it's
geared to brainwash women into thinking
you need to be masculine you need to be
a boss babe you need to be a boss [__]
you need to be this corporate girl right
and think about how stupid that is if
you're telling millions of women like
yeah you can all be CEOs how many
[__] CEO positions are there
and that's the thing they sell this to
women like I was thinking about it
everyone in my high school because I
went to um a Catholic like private high
school you were elected as a loser if
you didn't go to college yeah when women
from it's like interesting because we
have things that the culture pushes and
things that are better for your biology
and it's like you you really your
fertility starts to decline after like
well they say 90 of your eggs are gone
after 30. if you're single by 30 you
have more likely to never have children
than to have them well that's a fear
that people like to instill into people
which no one isn't necessary because
we're not talking about you no I know
but no but I'm telling you it is a fear
that people try to instill into people
because even in the world of today it is
not really I would say it's not a good
idea to have a lot of children anyway so
if you went into 13 you have one or two
then that's fine Aya's gonna take no
right the odds are so don't be scared
you've shifted from blaming men to
blaming Ai No I'm just saying the world
the world is not conducive for people to
behave in those ways anymore and that's
why
I think women should know if you're 30
and you're still single if you're in a
relationship the odds are a bit
different because you have to first you
have to find a guy that wants to marry
you right so like that's step one and we
only majority is a gigantic mountain to
climb yeah and then step two that you
want to marry back another huge hurdle
and so if you hit 30 and you're single
and you have no kids the odds are it's
you it's like you're 60 70 likely to
never have children and like like and
this isn't propaganda this isn't fear
this is just the numbers yep and then
you know the the risks that happen post
35 like post 35 you know what they call
the the pregnancy after you're 35 years
old you know what this classified as
yeah what's it called uh geriatic
geriatric correct geriatric pregnancy
right which means you're an old [__]
that's pregnant
can have Jewel
Ry now well at least they can but is it
possible for them to have them and for
the babies not to be [__] and for
the babies as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible